I literally just looked up shirtless
anime men and here we go I don't know
how much of that you heard oh we didn't
know you were there a lot I know you
were there my gosh for us welcome back
to big mood today we have a very special
guest we have Devin Clegg here why did
you change your name it all did you no
no I didn't look like okay yay yay seven
are we allowed to say what show you're
on or do we just say it no we can't yeah
yeah on a reality TV show hey our
Instagram and find out which one yeah
yeah yeah you should change your zoom
name to your Instagram so people can
know yeah oh that is my Instagram I
don't got any cute names for my yeah
it's actually making sure that it will
make sure it's in there yeah there you
go so she's a no she's in a reality show
we can't say which one but I'm sure you
guys if you guys do a quick google
you'll be able to find it Google Queens
right now no don't Google my head don't
google my name it's literally the
ugliest screenshots of yeah thank you
for being here today I actually wanted
to talk about that the most on the
today's episode is I just don't think
people understand we all watch reality
TV you we all like reality TV and people
that say they don't watch it they're
lying it's a guilty pleasure that we all
have and I think the reason cuz you know
Steve and I were talking about this how
we really didn't get into reality TV
until this past year and I think we like
it because you kind of form opinions on
people right away with whoever you're
watching it with and then you just talk
[ __ ] together so you don't see a people
like they're not real and you're in your
head but then I think it gets out of
hand when people start going on social
media harassing these people and like
really really treating them like they're
not people I mean for us it's just like
a fun thing we do in our living room
were like oh we're on this person psycho
no now we're on this person
side but you know the way that people
treat reality TV stars afterwards I feel
like it gets really personal so I wanted
you to talk a little bit about that and
and how your experience has been both
like on the show and then the aftermath
yeah definitely I think with reality TV
it is one of those weird things because
we're inviting you into our lives so
it's like yes you get that open opinion
but I think the problem is with my
certain reality TV show it blew up and
it's currently like one of the most
popular shows right now on that a
certain Network and for some reason this
fan base it's not necessarily a fan base
it's a hate base right yeah I just
always messaging me about it
imagine what we get and then just like
times up I like a thousand I can't write
oh yeah pretty much
pretty much it's it's really bad there's
with this certain TV show at least I
haven't seen this with other reality TV
shows as there's like all of these fan
pages and groups with like five hundred
thousand followers and it's just about
like exposing our personal lives like
trying to dig for the truth in that kind
of stuff because they just want to keep
getting to know more and more and
unfortunately what you see on TV you see
snippets and so for this certain fan
base like me and the cast mates have
just came to the conclusion that they
feel like they own the show and we're
kind of like invading on it so it get
really nasty and bad I've had a hate
mail I've had people call like CPS on me
I've had yeah I had like someone sent
like um what is it the dog police I'm
not sure like animal animal control to
my mom's house to take ji hoons dog like
that kind of stuff and it's like they do
this because they want like I think they
think we're filming 24/7 and then they
can make like a story
I don't oh my god like there's no
editing involves its so yeah same to me
it's so crazy to me how people don't
kind of understand like look if you
don't work in entertainment in media
until understand you don't know like
certain things but it's just so insanely
people understand timelines you know
like for instance there are times when
we would film like 24 episodes in one
day and then the comments be like why do
they always wear the same thing every
day all the time do they only own one
shirt and it's just like how do you not
like what they freak out if I was no
laughs yeah ladies not that sort of
friends where um Joey is dating a girl
who's crazy she's like wait wait if
you're on TV how are you standing in
front of me - it's insane to me that
people to understand time when it comes
to media like this it's insane to me how
much time people spend investing into
other people's life after the show is
over because like for me like I said
before it's like we're watching our
living room for an hour maybe two hours
we're binge watching or whatever and
then when we turn it off we don't think
about it anymore like it's not like so
we don't go find those people and harass
them and like ask them why they made
their life choices or whatever and it's
crazy to me how invested people get and
I I don't know what type of people what
like happened in their childhoods that
made them be this way but it's it's
amazing how big a scale it is like it's
a mass amount of people and sometimes I
go follow I go look at reality TV stars
instagrams or like their Twitter's or
whatever just to read their comments and
make sure that they're okay like
mentally like the way that they're
handling their comments says a lot about
how they are handling their lives and
like so many times I've wanted to just
like fight for them because it's so it's
so brutal and people just don't
understand and people understand that
editing makes the show look make you
look a certain way
yeah the network has a lot of control
over the storyline that they want to and
like so I know I've been messaging with
Devin for like the beginning bro I'm
like here's everything I think I'm sure
because someone said because we were
watching the show
it's almost like oh I think there's
someone who watches JK that's also on
the show so let me go I think I reached
out and I was like hey girl I was like
oh my god I watched on YouTube all the
time I remember at one point I was
messaging you and I was like hey these
comments are ridiculous like don't take
that [ __ ] personal but now after like a
year you've kind of grown like you've
grown to definitely ya know so the
beginning was bad because I feel I feel
like there's a huge difference between
cuz I started YouTube just recently and
I feel like there's this huge difference
because reality TV for some reason with
me it just happened really fast and that
fan climb just happened so fast I feel
like at least in different industries
you kind of build up to that but this
was like boom it's in your face you're
not ready you're not prepared they don't
tell you this and it just happened all
so fast like I felt like a normal person
and then all of a sudden I have like
thousands of people like just messaging
me about my kids like my parenting all
this crazy stuff and it's like they
don't know you know they don't see like
everything and so at first I did not
handle it well because a lot of them
like attack kids on that show and it's
not just my kids I could attacked but
these adults like will attack the kids
on the show and yeah I'm a mama bear so
of course I'm gonna freak the [ __ ] out
because those were my babies yeah and so
with that I did not handle it well I
would go off on people all the time but
as time like passed I've kind of gotten
used to it with this show it's really
weird there's just anything you do is
going to turn into an article I've been
in Utah for like two days and it's
already all over and they're like oh why
is she and Utah why is she in America
yeah and it's just like so crazy but now
I've kind of handled it a little better
but I'm still like weird about my kids
and I always will be worried about my
kids when they attack me should yeah and
like for me it's I'm fine now it doesn't
bug me
the only thing that really bugs me is so
many people think I got plastic surgery
when I [ __ ] did it oh girl what did
you because your makeup got better or
something cuz I was like Sam like in the
last I don't know a couple months like
yours yeah look have no creep do like
it's like high school makeup to like
college makeup yeah whatever you did
[ __ ] facetune we look ourselves an
honest [ __ ] we love on his [ __ ] no I
was like that she you guys you guys look
very similar I kept thinking I was
watching Jess yeah like certain facial
expressions Jess make like yeah brown
hair Gina I know I'm not used to
brunette anymore this is [ __ ] dope
wait I got something to change I can see
the difference okay so I'm there to be
fair I did not do my makeup on the show
I did not do that to be fair so I don't
know what they were going for I don't
know what they were trying to do I got
in trouble for saying this but I don't
give a [ __ ] because I've already said it
so many times so I don't know if they
like wanted to make me look weird on the
show - like downplay like to add drama
to make it look like I'm a catfish but
it's like I've been facetiming ji-hoon
for like five months at that point and
they they had like a makeup artist and I
was eight months pregnant filming and I
think a lot of people forget that I was
pregnant yeah you looked hot as [ __ ] oh
yeah I completely forgot that you were
pregnant the whole time I would I would
give you on my credit cards yeah no I uh
they did my hair and makeup and with the
show I have a lot of tattoos
I am very the way I dress is very tomboy
and I guess they didn't like that so of
course they hid all my tattoos they kind
of wanted me to look more girly and my
kind of go for a kpop feel
and I'm not gonna say what show it is
because you know I can't do that but I'm
just saying that I can say this without
saying the name but they tried to make
me look like a Korea boo at all cost and
they did the same thing to ji hoon' as
well that was the storyline right it
does yeah
it sucks for me cuz I look like [ __ ]
poo but it's fine
I remember there was like there was I
don't know if it was um like on
Instagram somewhere or like some shitty
TMZ thing or something but there was
like an image of you were like your eye
shadow was like kind of [ __ ] up like
it wasn't blended out or something and
then like people were talking so much
[ __ ] it was like oh my god how
embarrassing is that like a makeup
artist like who who hires that you don't
like the makeup artist they blame the
person I know they didn't think this
young purpose ah because you know the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills and all
yeah their makeup artist isn't doing
them that kind of dirty so no they did
me dirty first shirts it's like weird
because it was just us that they did
that to and for some reason like we
still don't know why they but they just
didn't like the look they they said I
couldn't have my tattoos on TV for
copyrights I think that's was their okay
but I did I did get lip fillers I'm very
open about that I got lip fillers and I
did get my teeth fixed so those are the
only things I've had damn okay guys I
didn't realize that they controlled I
mean like I know that reality TV
controls a lot I didn't really suppose
like all the way down here look to you
like going into makeup every day because
I'll have you know now I'm surprising
you said you have makeup artists in the
show every day because I've been
watching like some old episodes and some
of those people needed makeup artists
like how you gonna go on national TV
with a giant ass pimple on your face and
just and lipstick on your teeth you know
so I was really surprised to hear they
have a big part is for you yeah it was a
one it was just for me
like I think season the next season
that's about to
come out there was a little bit more
involved with the hair and makeup like
they did pick how they wanted that a
little bit more with season two which
sucks because I just really wanted to
look like Devon the the entire season
and it's just one of those things that I
just felt like I wasn't portrayed right
and that's the one thing I hate because
then it does start up the plastic
surgery rumors like nose jobs and that
kind of stuff but all it is is styling
and the fact that you know I'm not
pregnant anymore all filled out with
some idea maybe I was gonna say I'm
really curious like how is it actually
living in Korea are you allowed to talk
about that oh yeah I can talk about
Korea that's like a difference between
like living you know here and there like
what's the best takeaway or like would
you not expect um I went to a nightclub
that was fun cooking club it was not a
booking Club I did not go a little
bucking Club I was a booking Club do you
want to explain it no you can I want to
hear your take on okay so I know about
this because back when I was a go-go
dancer I would build and booking clubs
and my family my older brother my my
friend um he was like had security there
and my friends are like you never brings
him looking love having you and they
took me so a booking club is a Korean
thing where guys can go in and they can
buy tables and like sit down get drinks
and stuff like that so think of it like
dick event like a big Cheesecake Factory
with a bunch of tables with a giant
dance floor in the middle and all the
men body tables there's music loud music
DJs the answer is whatever and the girls
okay so literally the waiters there will
grab the girls and be like hey come sit
at this table and they're like pimp you
up so like each table they come sit here
sit here sit here wait those patrons
like oh yeah yeah yeah so the waiters
will grab you and have you sit on men's
like yet men's tables like hey meet
these guys meet these guys so it's like
it's almost like speed dating the Korean
way yeah kind of yeah exactly
the code is so it's kind of an
understanding where if the guys offer
you a drink
they like you and they're like they want
you to stay but if there's like oh hey
they'll offer you tree then you can just
be like okay I want to go to the
bathroom I'll be back and you just never
come back or the other way around is if
you don't like the guys even if they do
offer you drinking you don't like the
guys think so what's the expectation
here you're gonna hook up yeah thing no
you you have to hook up yes if you stay
you're hooking up no I I haven't been to
a club like that ji-hoon has he went to
those all the time he tells me all about
it yeah they do have they do no special
wristbands that my friend always gave me
it's like a bright yellow wristband that
tells the waiters do not bug this girl
don't grab her so she's all commits yeah
anyway she's in a relationship or
something or just don't she's just there
to like dance yeah I went to Hongdae is
a pimp in place freakin Levin it's so
cool it's very like just party central
there's like 30 nightclubs in like one
Street right and I don't really have
anything to compare it to just because
I've actually never been to a nightclub
in America I did never experience that
but I can are you trying to try to go
out dude
no I've never went to a nightclub I've
never had a sleepover I've never done
like Jack Shea and I'm like I was
complaining about it - ji-hoon and he's
like okay I'll take you to a club and I
was like I don't want to go to a club
you know guys are gonna like be up on me
and he's like no they're not like and I
was like bit no it's interesting so I'm
gonna go off based on my friends
experience and movies but so the Korean
nightclubs are really interesting so
like everybody's really [ __ ] beautiful
sorry I curse too much I need to stop
doing that
everything yeah everyone's really
freaking beautiful like all the guys
look like they just came out of a kpop
video everyone's really tall which is
nice because I'm five nine so like it's
it's just heaven on earth for me and the
visuals are great but what they do is
like they they know you come in with a
dude right so what they do is they wait
for your dude to leave to go to the
bathroom right are you serious yeah
and like they would watch me right and
they would just wait for him to leave
and he would leave to go to the bathroom
and they don't even ask you they don't
do anything they just come right up to
you grab your arm and pull you straight
to their table and you know like I don't
know if it's because I'm a foreigner but
they just really want to practice
English like if you're a foreigner you
go a night here nobody's getting cold
left and right and so this guy pulled me
he was this cute little dorky guy
whatever right he had some major balls
but he was like really sure he was like
overweight his cute little boy with you
know glasses so the only ugly one in the
club exactly yeah and I think he was
like watch boys he's adorable until he
got creepy but oh no he's not adorable
yes so he like gets me a drink he's like
dancing he's trying to talk to me I
can't remember what the heck he said but
he was whispering in my ear and then
that's when he like licked my ear yeah I
need to get out of here
and so ji-hoon finds me and this dude
doesn't save me he just hands me a drink
and says have fun Oh what wait yeah yeah
wait was he like mad or he just like
didn't give a [ __ ] no honey he thought
it was funny
hey dude I know he just thought it was
like a blossom she I don't know February
I don't know
[Laughter]
yeah he's interesting but like
he's interesting I ditched the dude I'm
looking for him and then this like
beautiful guy comes up to me he's
talking to me and you know ji-hoon Mike
sees us I'm like yes he's gonna come
save me it's fine he's gonna get mad
this beautiful beautiful guy is hardened
he's like the most beautiful guy in the
nightclub he obviously had a lot of
money cuz he had like 15,000 dollar
bottle like he was mad money was it it
was like six to that buzz cut like you
know the classy one with the dark hair
and a turtle he was good-looking and he
was just being very flirtatious and the
whole time I just really wanted to leave
and I'm like ji hoons just staring at me
and I'm waiting for him to come save me
like he should you know like you throw
hands or something right and he's just
sitting there smiling and laughing maybe
do you think he enjoys it like you know
some men are into that fetish wise you
know they like seeing their chicks with
it being wanted by other dudes no
because like once I got away he like got
really angry at me and started a fight
in the car yeah yeah he's he's a he's
something else
um but it was interesting cuz like the
way and like I noticed about the guys in
Korean nightclubs this they're like
super like respectful even though
they're like grabbing up on you but
they're doing it in like a respectful
way really or is it just foreign and
you're like oh it's cute no this guy's
so like I had a tube top on and he was
like fixing it and pulling it up making
sure like my boobs weren't falling out
and making sure I looked good fixing my
hair and he was like there you go you
look beautiful now yeah they're just
very like titties up Yeah right you know
they're just like super like it's like
this weird romantic thing where they
describe your arm and they make you feel
like a princess for five minutes except
for that you're liquor and like going
off of like my friends when they go to a
nightclubs in America I just see like a
lot of grinding and like all that kind
of stuff but like in Korea
just felt like this cute little romantic
moment but that was nice that was like a
long ramble but yeah I loved that about
Korea the food's great I have an
intercom system inside my apartment and
get woken up everyday by it so that's
great well in your apartment when you go
home are you sleeping with comfortable
sheets are you sleeping with comfortable
bedding because if not you really should
check out Buffy's dream Devin we weren't
Devenish you would feel very used when
we do a transition but I just gotta say
that I genuinely [ __ ] freaking love
Buffy
especially if you sleep with someone
else that is a hot bodied night sweat
type of person and need something a
little cooler at night while you like to
feel comforted highly recommend Buffy
it's the most comfortable bedding
everything is made from ultra smooth
eucalyptus fiber that feels softer than
cotton it really really does you can
look just by over is breathable and cool
to the touch to help maintain the ideal
sleeping temperature and feel cozy
without overheating they offer
everything from cult favorite comforters
to pillows and sheets I have everything
by the way I have the sheets I have the
pillow covers I have the duvet covers
you need it all it's earth friendly all
the products are cruelty free
hypoallergenic no down feathers or
animal products in there customers love
Buffy the products have almost 20,000
five-star reviews I'm like half of those
plus an overall rating of 4.6 stars
believe the hype Buffy order a book
Buffy right now offers a free trial you
can try a comforter in your own bed for
free and if you don't love it you can
return it at no cost for $20 off your
Buffy comforter visit Buffy CO and enter
mood once again that's $20 off your
Buffy comforter visit clásico and enter
mood mode you know what else I would
like to do is give another shout out to
our other sponsor door - hungry -
American food so much hate cooking oh
right oh yeah I hate cooking especially
scrambled eggs and bacon do you want
yeah American food delivered to your
door Devon all the time oh my gosh stop
guys stop making her do that okay
restaurants okay door - is the app that
brings you the food you're craving right
now right to your door we all know this
ordering is easy open the door - app
choose what you want to eat and your
food will be left safely outside your
door with our with the new contactless
delivery drop-off setting you've counted
on restaurants now they're counting on
you
well the dining rooms may be closed
they're still open for delivery many of
your favorite local restaurants really
need the support right now to stay alive
during the pandemic so order something
if you got the extra cash like just
support the local restaurants guys I'm
also right now our listeners can get
five dollars off their first order of 15
dollars or more and zero delivery fees
for their first whole month when you
download the door - app and enter code
big mood that's five dollars up your
first order and zero delivery fees for a
month when you download the door - app
in the App Store and enter code big mood
for five dollars off your first order
with door - big mood big movie mood
great I wanted to ask you Devon about
also so your dips your offer reality
show TV you're dealing with people to
think they know your lives life and like
want to comment on it and want to hate
you for it and then you're also in a
foreign country and dealing with the
culture shock of that how do you balance
like how do you keep saying I don't I
have mental breakdowns all the time I'm
live stream I can't imagine no it's it's
really a lot oh yeah it's a lot because
not only is it reality TV and and you
know so many people are watching you
it's like this weird kind of Fame
because it's like I may not have a large
following on social media but if I go
out in public in America I get stopped
because they feel like they can just
because it's it's a TV show so it's one
of those weird situations in the same in
Korea I get stopped - and I don't
trust people I can't have friends in
Korea I made a friend group and they
leaked like my miscarriage they leaked
all this information about me yes so
I've had to cut almost everyone out of
my life and it's been rough and so what
I'm doing now to deal with it is I'm
just like focusing on fun things like
side projects I can do for myself and
that kind of thing like while I'm in you
time trying to like hang out with like
the friends I can which is weird by the
way because you know with this reality
TV Fame I was like oh hell yeah I can't
wait to have all these fake-ass [ __ ]
friends I'm so excited because I've
never had friends those like freak yeah
I can't wait I'm gonna have all these
friends I don't care if they're fake
they're gonna just be my friend is this
matter but like I just I was talking to
Jess about this I just hung out with
like my real friends that I had been
friends with for like 10 years and he
ghosted me after hanging out and I'm
like yeah so like my friends are like
ghosting me instead of like you know
having all these awesome fake friends I
don't know which one I prefer but it's
like super weird it's a super weird
lifestyle especially Korea I don't have
friends out there ji-hoon does not speak
English
I know bare-minimum Korean and then with
us we were in quarantine since January
in Korea so I was locked in the house
for a very long time and then on top of
filming for the next season it's just
been a lot because it's unfortunate
because I can't justify things I can't
tell the truth on what may have been cut
out or how like what really happened
that kind of stuff so it sucks because
you're in this weird monopoly and you
can't fully like say anything and it's
because you signed an NDA or some yes
exactly you like sell your soul to the
reality TV gods they'll make you yeah
famous but they're like taking full
control of your life right and they get
to set the narrative that's what I hate
about that I also had a question because
so I got really curious about the whole
process of reality TV stars because
currently watching an old season of love
island and in that season two of the
people and it took their lives and I
just lie and I couldn't I couldn't watch
it the same way anymore after that yeah
and and so it made me go down this
rabbit hole of what sort of care these
people being given like afterwards to
deal with it mentally and like because
that's a huge just like just trauma so
like apparently on this show on love
Island they say that there's a pre care
where they like screen people for making
sure that they're saying and mentally
stable first and then they they have
aftercare where they set up set you up
with a psychologist and make sure that
you have a therapist to talk to but um
we do is it that way across the board on
all reality TV shows is it was it like
that for you what was their process like
definitely not I think I think [ __ ] you
in or not yeah
they find people who are messed up like
that's the point you see they try to
find yeah like there's something crazy
about this person or they're broken in
this way or we can exploit their life
for one reason or another for sure it's
like they're trying to do yeah for sure
and like with with us and like I feel
like with my cast mates and none of them
are really dealt with depression but
that's for other reasons that I won't
say and I think when you're being
truthful with your story that's when you
actually do hit that depression point
and I've had really bad depression it's
been super bad lately and that is a huge
reason why I am back in America to get
the help I need to make sure I'm okay as
a person because I do have two kids as
for the TV reality world
I have also deep dive into all of the
suicides that have happened all of the
messed up stuff that has happened and
you'd be surprised how many people are
killing themselves who are on reality TV
yeah yeah it's a lot a girl just killed
herself about three days ago she was on
a popular Netflix reality show in Japan
caller
house yeah oh wait I've seen Tara's
house under well not maybe I don't know
if it was that season or not yeah she's
on this season so her ups are still
airing and it's because reality TV
people people soak that in and just
because we put ourselves out there on a
show they do believe that they can have
opinion about us which they can that's
fair but there's a difference between
having an opinion and purposely trying
to coax someone purposely trying to hurt
an individual because I don't care
people can have an opinion about me all
day yes I signed up for this I was aware
of that but they need to also realize
how show business works and I think
people are just so brainwashed that if
you're not in the industry you're never
going to understand that and with me I
just feel like the way my story was
portrayed was as if I didn't know Korean
culture as if I fetish sighs I can't say
that word I always say like Korean men
are a fetish to me like this weird stuff
that's like hey I thought that was super
weird when I was watching it I was like
why did he make her look like a total
dumbass I'm like come on you know yeah
they made it look like I didn't go to
school even though I graduated early and
it's just like they they they coax you
and it's all in the editing which is
unfortunate but yes it's like when they
asked me do you like Korean guys it's
like well okay my my fiance's Korean
like is that a trick question like how
do you answer that exactly well have you
dated a korean before well I dated one
cream before when I was like 16 so yes
now you know so it's it's things like
that that were way taken out of context
and it's the thing that I've been
learning Korean for two years and the
way it's just edited makes me look like
I had know nothing about the culture and
it's like dude there's a reason why I
was going to Korea there's a reason why
I met him how I did and I don't think
people put two and two together
think it was just really like a bad view
making me look like a Korea boo which
wasn't the case I don't know what they
were trying to do but season two will be
better they promise that's good that's
good highly highly recommend if you're
not in the industry and you don't feel
like you couldn't understand this just
from us talking about it highly
recommend the show unreal have you guys
seen that show think I almost started
but I didn't I didn't finish it but I
get what a whole freaking good it's so
good and I think it was either written
or produced by an ex producer of The
Bachelor or an ex someone that used to
work on The Bachelor and so it was like
using all of these behind-the-scenes
experiences to show how they manipulate
the cast how they change the narrative
how they edit it to make it look a
certain way and how they manipulate the
fans to buy into a certain person's side
and how they pick the heroes and the
villains ahead of time so that like they
can paint the story and really push it
in that direction and they get really
upset if their person that they chose as
a hero isn't winning or if somebody
chose as a villain is getting liked more
by the fans and it's so interesting
because after you see that show even
though it's a scripted drama it's very
entertaining it's very well-written but
you'll you won't look at reality TV the
same because you'll see like where they
manipulated people where the edits are
the way they narrate like how it all
comes together full circle was how they
wanted it to come together full circle
so fascinating you know yeah it's sad I
think with my certain story what they do
was ours wasn't scripted and we made
sure it wasn't scripted and I think
that's why they wanted like a little bit
of control with like the way we looked
and that kind of thing because we
wouldn't wouldn't do anything like that
because we wanted to show our love story
and that kind of stuff and I think with
other reality shows not mine
mine of course is a hundred percent real
guys just so you know but I wasn't
talking about the reality TV shows being
screwed to put the
like the show under yeah and I was like
yeah yeah I think like start some shows
they they have a baseline script where
they hope these oh yeah definitely they
do i doing reality TV has ruined reality
TV for me i can't watch process behind
it and like long takes in between things
and you're like oh this is actually like
yeah and since years wasn't unscripted
and think you had real moments in there
do you ever feel like it was kind of
changed in editing or manipulated a
certain way oh definitely definitely
things are definitely snipped apart with
reality TV to build that drama you know
like to make it look more suspenseful
but I think like the problem with my
story is it's so real and that's what
scares me because I can't sit there and
be like oh yeah no that didn't happen
but it's like oh god like I think that's
the fear with with my certain segments I
can't speak for every cast member and
that kind of thing but it was the fact
that mine was so real that I'm like oh
god I don't want people to see this and
with this upcoming season I'm like oh
[ __ ] because the stuff that happened it
was bad and I think like I ain't gonna
lie I think some of the things that have
happened might make reality history and
that terrifies me Oh
shares of what I'm really making me want
to watch this yeah
back I was planning on watching season
two but now I'm for sure yeah but that's
it it's a shame and with depression it
definitely comes with this business just
because of all the NTAs and you don't
feel like yourself anymore and it's like
like look at Paris Hilton right she did
reality TV and they made her look you
know like this dumb person this dumb
character but in reality the reason why
she did reality TV was cuz she wanted to
break away from her family and make her
own money and start her own business and
she's actually this really smart
intelligent person and she holds on to
that Paris Hilton character even though
that's not who she really is and I think
she kind of knew though like she knew
that that would sell and she played eggs
out it a bit like she was smart enough
to know to play up that character in
order to get the eyes on her but she's
actually smart behind that a lot of
people don't realize that the fact that
they're sitting there and they're
talking [ __ ] and gossiping while you're
playing into exactly what they want you
your name their name is in your mouth
and that's what they want and you're
just falling right into the trap so
they're they don't realize that people
are smarter than they portray themselves
to be on TV yeah it's it boggles my mind
how much people play like fall into when
you're watching it like just buying
every little and how easy it is yeah
this is so true I also think another
psychological factor with reality TV
stars versus traditional celebrities is
like you were talking about earlier
Devon like you weren't trained it didn't
get built up into celebrity status
you're just like BAM now a bunch of
people know who you are out of nowhere
like you're going from here zero to 60
and for you know traditional celebrities
not only do they have tons of
representation beforehand a lot of them
are covered by unions but they're also
like they have PR reps they also have
money like you have money to have a
coach to teach you how to say things
like there's a there's a lot of
production that goes into shaping their
branding as a person and they're trained
on that before and after and during and
all throughout the process when you're a
reality TV star like you're gifted that
and then you don't make it like a ton of
money like it's not like Brad Pitt and
then afterwards especially when they
move on to a new season and some of
these shows like like love Island like
talking about earlier where people love
you hate you your everything is all
these eyeballs are on you and then they
completely forget about you like you're
back to oblivion and they're on to the
new the new cast and that's hard to deal
with to go through a shitstorm like that
and then try to go back to a normal life
like a normal lifestyle is super super
hard and I totally commend you for that
because that's just like that's just
like so I can't even I can't even
imagine like I can't even fathom yeah
it's pretty much like impossible to go
to a normal lifestyle like with my
certain show I did there is all these
different couples right and then out of
the few bunch there are certain couples
who are picked to continue right it
feels like a giant casting process
honestly to see who's gonna be on the
main show most couples on the show only
get one season right so then they're
done and they taste that they grasp that
and then for those popular picks they
just keep moving on to season to season
to season right and unfortunately like
the people who don't who want that who
do the show for bad reasons because
there's a lot of people who do this show
who just want the fame just to get quick
they kind of make up a story line to
like make up their backstory or whatever
exactly I can't stand those people I go
on I talk I'm so blunt about it on
Instagram I've gotten in trouble so many
times for you like bashing cast members
for being so fake because I just hate
that because I didn't I didn't do the
show to do that I did the show thinking
would be fun and a life-changing
experience which it was and it's like I
can't go out in public without people
stopping me and asking me about my
relationship
I went out alone the other day and
there's articles already being like oh
is she single what's going on and I
can't get a normal job if even if I
wanted to get a normal job thankfully
because we were one of those couples
that were picked to continue I can make
an income online and kind of build that
up like that following up on my own and
have my own following so I can do this
for however long as possible when the
show's over and hopefully once the
showed phase away and this fades away if
it's gonna fade away I can like regain
that normal life again but I you never
know you never know you so would you go
out you just see people just randomly
snapping photos of you and just
following you around and [ __ ] like it's
it's weird because like I was talking
about this with my girlfriend and like
in my head like I'm like oh I don't I
don't think I'm famous because you know
numbers like number wise I'm like oh I
don't think that but we talked about it
there's like this huge difference
between reality TV Fame movie star Fame
music Fame Instagram Fame YouTube Fame
right and I feel like people with
reality TV they put you on towards like
the movie star type of people and they
follow you you have paparazzi you have
random people filming you and coming up
to you because in their head it's like
oh you're on my TV screen I didn't I
didn't choose to watch you like for
example I didn't choose to watch you on
YouTube right for example like I don't
know how to explain that it's like you
choose to watch a youtuber you choose to
follow this music artist but with movies
and reality TV it's kind of forced down
their throats to know this person so in
their head they think oh it's okay to
film this person it's okay to go up to
this person and take pictures of them
and follow them and it's like this weird
thing that we are placed on the same
pedestal as a movie actor if that makes
sense when it comes to people
approaching you out in public and
article wise and paparazzi wise right
but we don't make that money so we don't
get the protection that we need I was in
Las Vegas a
for my for my birthday back in November
and we had gotten stopped at least 30
times and then these girls had actually
followed me into the bathroom you know
and they were trying to snap pictures of
me like going to the bathroom trying to
sell that [ __ ] to TMZ like oh look at
Devon or song you get in trouble for
that yeah cuz it's it's this weird Fame
it's like I don't feel famous I don't I
don't feel like that then like online I
don't feel like that I feel like a
normal person but then it's like no I
need to remember that this is the number
one show in America and it's on in 60
different countries and it's like it
doesn't get in your head like that
because a lot of these people who watch
this show you know they don't have
social media that kind of stuff it's the
age range is about 40 years old is the
normal age range for that so they're not
going to be like all up on Instagram you
know but but they think it's okay to
approach you in public and take pictures
of you and film you and there's just
been so many like bad stories leaked
about me and I like I'm scared to hang
out with anyone because I'm scared
they're gonna sell a story or someone's
gonna see us and assume something well I
guess you have to hang out with either
other reality people or like other
people in the industry then right exact
was hoping to get some secrets to sell
if that's okay like yep like a secret
girlfriend do you want do you just have
something going on it's another year
[Music]
secret lovers cancel esta - it's a TMZ
I'm like so down oh yeah no we've been
secret lovers for a year and we've got
this huge plan where she was gonna get
up on you guys and use you and then I
was like okay then I will go on yeah
we'll just dump it
yeah a real Millie seems mental health
though what we one of our sponsors
directly with mental health and that is
talk space if you feel like you cannot
afford or you don't have easy access to
a psychologist or a licensed therapist
um you can find one online at Gena you
want to talk about that a little bit
oh I thought you were taken over because
you're doing so well oh yeah oh thank
you
yeah so for those of you who really feel
like you want to go out there people for
some reason either one you can't afford
just how crazy the prices are or you
don't want to leave the house sometimes
I mean right now I don't think you
should leave the house you don't leave
the house this is true and I feel like I
don't know about you guys but when I'm
going through something I hit up the
girls cuz I need to talk about it right
then and there right so if you ever want
to do that talk space is there for you
because talking helps clean and simple
tax base is an online therapy app where
you can go on download it and you answer
a bunch of questions like what kind of
you know what kind of phones am i
dealing with what I want to work on what
I want to improve and they'll match you
with a bunch of different licensed
therapists if these people are real and
you get to choose like okay I want speak
to this person and you can change the
person whenever you want to I don't want
to explain it and make it awkward and
you get the support that you need on
wherever schedule works for you because
I don't know about you guys but I don't
want to wait a whole entire week and
like jumble everything together and try
to remember everything to speak to
someone once a week
with talk space you can message them
24/7 double texting triple Texan send
them voice messages send them video
messages of your ugly face crying if you
want them smoke your therapist okay okay
and it's from your phone or your
computer and they for when I was on it
they check their phone twice a day and
they'll message you like hey you know
like let's talk about this how do you
feel like this and they'll be there for
you instead of having to wait because
right when you're in your emotions you
want to talk about it right so one month
on talk space cost about the same amount
as a single in-person therapy session so
you already know it's worth it
you can send unlimited messages to your
therapist they'll engage with you at
least five days
and you'll never have to wait talk to my
therapist have experience in treating
depression anxiety substance abuse
trauma relationship issues food and
eating and much much more it's secure
and private and it uses the latest
encryption technology to store client
information I know when I had to log in
every time I had to punch in a code or
like actually scan my face Wow
yeah so um we don't need to talk
sometimes you know it happens and talk
space give us it gives us the support we
deserve by price we can afford match
with your perfect therapist today at
toxin acecomm or download the app and
use the promo code mood to get a hundred
dollars off your first month and help
support the show but also support your
brain that's tock space calm and the
promo code is mood I highly suggest it I
use it and it's helped me a lot so you
guys don't know you're crazy [ __ ] mm-hmm
no no no see because of top space my
therapist is losing her mind also
something that helps you mentally
physically it's also vitamins and today
our sponsor is care of which is a
vitamin and supplement subscription it's
a subscription based thing where you get
a box of vitamins and I like it because
I'm very simple I have like a monkey
brain where I like to go on and look at
pretty websites and say quizzes and
that's how you go on care of and you
figure out what vitamin C if they have a
cute quiz that you take and it asks you
what you want to do like what you want
to cure visit your brain your heart
immune system your vagina whatever that
you need right and then they'll compile
a list of vitamins that they think that
you should have and they send it to your
house so it is a wellness brand that
makes it easy to maintain your health
goals with a customized vitamin plan
that keeps you feel your best today and
supports you a long time it's
hassle-free and it makes taking your
vitamins and supporting your health
goals attainable it comes in a cute box
with like little things that you pull
out and you rip it open and you take
your vitamins and it's quality that you
can see and taste it's there's protein
powders which are made of real
ingredients that you can recognize like
organic cocoa and pink Himalayan sea
salt the packets that
you get are also eco-friendly which I
really really love because I don't want
individual packs of plastic crap
it's made of compostable films and
there's a ton of info on how to compose
them on the care of website and so I've
been taking it and I love it because if
even the thing I like about is that they
ask you like can you take big pills if
you can twisting like a let's row so
it's super cute it's really easy and it
makes me feel better about myself
because I'm taking the vitamins that I
want to take in a note it is so now for
50% off your care of order to take care
of calm and enter the code it's one word
big mood 50 for 50% off again for 50%
off your first care of order go to take
care of calm and enter the code big mood
50mm Gina back to back ad reads sorry
take a break now you're on a back go
take a shot so we're back to our story
you are currently back in America having
a kind of a break and how is how are the
kids like I do you are they with you yes
my kids are with me they're actually
upstairs running around and I keep
thinking oh my god the mics gonna pick
it up oh thank you man they're great
they're wonderful my daughter is happy
to see her family I think it was
affecting her pretty badly towards the
end of quarantine
so it's always nice to you see the
family kind of be able to speak English
and you know not baby talk to everyone
I'm around so it's been it's been really
nice just having like some human
interaction with my family because in
Korea I didn't you know I'm with ji-hoon
- who doesn't speak English so I have to
speak really slow to him
then I have the two kids who I obviously
have to speak very slow to um but but
they're really good they they really
love Korea they're having a blast in
Korea but I think they're also really
happy to be home my son is walking now
he's 1 years old loving mood they get to
experience both cultures you know
definitely I it's it's really helped
both of them grow as individuals and
it's so fascinating to see like my
daughter adapt to it and then it's just
fascinating to see my son grow up with
both cultures I'm not gonna lie I think
he's actually like you know acting more
like me and my daughter yeah my
daughter's adapting more to like the
Korean lifestyle sponges man is she
picking up Korean oh yeah she could
swear all the swear words in Korean
[Laughter]
about the negatives and stuff how it's
taking its toll on you but what
positives have you seen at this like I'm
sure like have you gotten messages from
people who are really supportive like
really sweet so that's like what are
some nice things that have happened oh
yeah so many so I have got to meet
people I never thought I would ever be
in my lifetime like you guys for example
you know stuff like that and yeah I just
think it's it's like those opportunities
are amazing and then of course like I
have a really diehard fan base I think
they're more they go towards my youtube
a little bit more and like that fan base
is so supportive and I've never like had
so many people reach out to me and tell
me like I look sad one day and might be
like we care about you are you okay and
it's like a really good feeling and I've
made a lot of friends in New York in the
music business which is weird I never
thought thought about that but interest
yeah I'm like in this crew now
apparently with them and they're just
super so
part of of me emotionally and that kind
of thing and I have even though I've
lost a lot of like friends and my my
real life I've made a lot of internet
friends which has been really great and
then obviously of course the fans like
they are so supportive of me
they're amazing without them I wouldn't
have these opportunities I'm able to
work at home and stay with my kids and
I'm getting offered jobs that I never
would have expected to ever do and I
think that is truly amazing
and I appreciate all those people for
giving me the opportunity to do stuff
that I've always wanted to do but have
been way too scared to do and now I can
do those things and then also be at home
and be with my kids but then if I need a
break from my kids I can actually go and
travel now because I have that means now
and I think that's just amazing I have a
question do you like would you do it all
over again knowing all the negatives and
then like not really knowing how it's
gonna end because it's like there's a
lot of negative and some good positives
but just reads my Instagram she's like
damn like damn yeah there's a lot of
negatives but honestly like I wouldn't
give it up for the world because I am
able to be at home with my kids and I
can do the things I can at home because
beforehand I was working six days a week
at a furniture store and I was pulling
14-hour shifts just to provide for my
family and I'm still pulling long shifts
of course because I'm at home but I'm
able to you know interact and give them
what they need and even though I was a
teen mom I want to still be able to
raise them and I'm happy that I am able
to raise them and be a home with them
but then with this opportunity I can
still kind of experience my youth if
that makes sense
so I'm getting like the best of both
worlds in that case I think doing Jewish
you're able to
like separate - like you're not so fully
into like what everyone thinks about you
because if you would still do it again
and you're like well I see the positives
of being able to raise my kids and the
way I want to and things like that it's
like you're not letting it get to you
the way it seems like unfortunately some
other people have who have gone so far
as to take their own life after it yeah
I mean wow like I guess if you're gonna
do it you have to be fairly stable yeah
that's what I really liked about you on
the show to be honest like I just felt
like you were super grounded you're very
articulate you're very relatable even no
matter how they tried to paint you at
any point with their makeup or whatever
or like yeah I found you to just be
really relatable I was like wow anyone
would feel that way in that situation I
really liked that so I'm happy that key
opportunities are coming for you thank
you so much that means a lot because a
lot of people are on ji-hoon side and
I'm just like you guys are about holes
like what his side I hate that [ __ ] like
what I have a relationship online too
I'm like why are you all like sticking
up for Joe for [ __ ] I'm like you weren't
there okay you don't [ __ ] know the
story
you don't know they'll never know it
yeah I never know yeah no I know but I
know and generally on a high level of
being white girls the way they should
yeah that's right watch I want to go
make like a fake it like a fenced
account now is Devon Clegg's
coolest fan ever definitely not Gina and
I'm just gonna defending everything
someone's gonna make that [ __ ] down just
say some dumb [ __ ] you guys ever think
it's me sexing you like hey is this you
or not so I feel I really like so my big
person I'm a big like um self-reflecting
person where it kind of like a lot of
times I sit down I'm like holy crap like
life is so strange like it's such a
weird thing like what I'm where I've
been what's going like do you feel that
a lot like if you just sit then you're
like holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ] weird
like my life is very strangest you
definitely do not live a normal life
compared to like 99.99% of the world do
you ever see yourself
TV or on whatever and you're like this
[ __ ] kinda sucks but life is [ __ ] cool
you know yeah every day every day I
think every night you know I have I have
a little balcony in Korea at my
apartment and like once I get the kids
to sleep
I literally just sit out there for hours
and just stare out into the sky and I'm
like oh my god this is the craziest
thing like I never thought I would be in
Korea in a high-rise apartment sitting
and seeing this beautiful view I
definitely didn't expect anyone to see
this like my life story but it it's so
crazy how things work out because I
think about small things like if I
changed one thing this opportunity would
have never happened and I reflect on
that all the time because I was actually
dating someone right before I met him
and he was a great guy he was super nice
he's very respectful and I feel bad he
actually really really really liked me
and it was a really good relationship
the problem was is he was young and he
was actually doing really good with his
career and he was blowing up Rob Lee
yeah he was getting like hired for like
Coachella like all this crazy [ __ ]
making all this money and traveling and
getting to go to like Coachella for free
and like all these cool places for free
and he wanted to take me to all these
like amazing events and he really wants
to showcase me and it's like you know at
the time I had a two-year-old and I'm
like you know I wish I could do these
things with you but I can't and I felt
like if I dated him and he took on that
role he wouldn't have been able to do
his dreams and I wasn't about to do that
to him and yeah and that's a huge reason
why I did break up with him and then you
know I ended up you know hooking up and
then got pregnant and then here we are
on the show too they were like how did
she get pregnant so fast like what's
that all about
and I'm like it only takes one sperm
the other part of that is is like
they're trying to paint it like well
that's suspicious but there would like
what was the scan like what would you
get out of it like like there at that
point like Hawaii yeah like I was like
well I could have understood maybe if
they introduced to him and he lived in a
[ __ ] palace and yeah crazy money
pouring out the window he was like a
regular guy living with the spirit yeah
I don't get what she's getting I know
just she doing songs yeah I totally want
that lifestyle uh ya know I would say
that what it is what is her it is I know
what it is
I know I know what your [ __ ] plans
are you're a BTS fan aren't you oh [ __ ]
I just saw she's my bias bro that's
exactly right and she is she wanted to
get like hurry as she wants go to Korea
so she can be BTS I knew it yeah but you
don't get it magnate it by a random guy
from the suburbs so like all I have to
do is get impregnated by and then I
wanna j-hope no I I do like kpop and I
try not to tell people that because I
don't think of my god no honestly like
when I was dating Jessica reactions I
got from people were like but why you
know I'm like what's the scam okay good
he's a youtuber but give me a [ __ ]
break like if I was like chasing some
[ __ ] don't you think I'd go a little
higher than a [ __ ] random asian
youtuber that's like so obscure like get
the [ __ ] out of here right well I feel
like they only do that with like white
girls yeah for sure like impossible that
a white girl would actually want to date
an Asian guy do 103 and like you know
want to actually be a family my mom's
way is she my dad she's not something
Nikki I know it hasn't come out yet
she's like yeah I get to figure it out
but I've been observing them for 33
years now
she's definitely scamming him somehow
your dad's Filipino right yeah your
mom's after Manny Pacquiao I thought
they'd know it okay
yes yes hey you'll see her snow even
though he wasn't really around in
mainstream media when they first met and
had me and probably not for another
couple decades but that was probably
yeah the long long game yeah yeah it's
interesting - do you ever get um when
you have your son around and you're in
public do well I guess you wouldn't get
this because people know you from TV but
um my mom would always get looks like
she was like people wouldn't believe
that she was my mom like people thought
she was the babysitter or a babysitter
yeah we're biggest dealer trying to sell
me know but like yeah they would they
wouldn't believe that she was my mom no
I get that I get that in Korea but it's
for a different reason it's because I'm
so young
oh yeah it's because I'm so young so
they're like who that lady's stealing
this baby and I actually got stuck in
customs on my way here and they wouldn't
let me leave cuz they're saying looks
pretty white dude I know he's way Wyatt
like what the hell like I mean I got
screwed I know like if you wanted a cute
asian baby you still got a pretty white
you can see the Asian in the eyes first
faces why I was like I'm so excited I
was looking at all these cute Korean
babies no way then I get a bond
I got a blonde Asian no it's good it'll
make you lots of money in the future so
I just have a baby is in Korea yeah it's
just our eight women yeah I'm really oh
they're Yeley it when they hear that I
have a kid at my age cuz I'm 23 they're
like oh my god you're a teenager well
that's what I think but here in America
I feel like all the at least in like
Midwest and all that like you want kids
by 24 like what are you doing yeah yeah
yeah I just I think the one thing that I
took away from this like one of the
things I've just in my mind bugs to
Shanna me it really pisses me off that
you can't fight people for being good
like what the [ __ ] man like that sucks
like if some like the holy girls
following you
something that shit's infuriating and
the fact that you can't fight them or
throw things at them but you know can
fight them if who can fight them we can
find me yeah we're just youtubers no
one's gonna give us we'll fight them all
oh my god that's what you should do
yes get an army your youtubers we can be
the new trap house guys yeah maybe like
it was a prank bros for my channel
social experiment
yeah you can't buy people bugs me you
know what I'm fighting for you that's
what we're doing you want a person like
Gina fighting for you by the way no I
think the most irritating thing actually
is I don't care about fans it's the Cass
I know I'm like I'm dying you have an
indie and you can't see [ __ ] is so
annoying
wait you guys all know yeah we meet each
other and I'll try and [ __ ] fight me
and I'm like what's your problem
well yeah they're there so for example
this one girl on this on this current
season now I'm not part of she she's in
a same-sex relationship I can't say I
mean obviously but she's in a same-sex
relationship and she just like I never
talked to her before ever and I didn't
know her story I haven't even watched
this season and she was like telling
production I was talking [ __ ] about her
and all this [ __ ] and she was like going
to bloggers and like all of this stuff
and saying that like I'm gonna fight her
I had it out for her all this dumb [ __ ]
and then her best friend is like a
youtuber but he's like a drama like a
drama youtuber who like reports on
celebrities and [ __ ] and he tried to
fight me on Instagram and I just didn't
acknowledge it I was like whatever
because I knew his YouTube channel and I
think they were butthurt that I wouldn't
fly with them so they made this
imaginary drama in their head to get me
in trouble with the network there's a
lot of people in this yeah yeah create
fake drama for their own personal a girl
we know you deal with it yeah does this
person have colorful hair her partner
does
okay got it and on that now you all just
got some extra tea but now let's not
give them and cancelled from the show
[ __ ] I was talking about show me this
our flew by you've been hey guys thank
you so much for coming on me just you're
so easy to talk to I love you and what
tell them where to find you tell them
we're like what YouTube channel and like
all your history I'm [ __ ] tell that yeah
so my Instagram is just Devin Clegg you
know I'm not cool I don't have any cool
names oh it's good my youtube channel is
a juni funny it's just I just do it for
fun and it all of a sudden got a lot of
followers so now I'm scared of it but I
still post I get that I still post three
times a week for you guys but yeah it's
great I really enjoy it it's it's
awesome that's possible links in the
description too so go find her follow
her and show her lots of love combat all
the haters yeah of you ever so much here
yeah exactly subscribe write us on
iTunes all that jazz thank you for being
here it's been a mood and we're checking
out we'll see you next week or we might
have a bonus episode you might have
already come out by the time I come out
guys love you guys from at Devon clicks
and definitely not Gina follow me
[Laughter]